welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in thor ragnarok saved the thor
movies by burning everything to the
ground while i have talked about this
movie's Easter eggs years ago there
remain overlooked visual and filmmaking
details from Taika Waititi that make
Ragnarok even more revolutionary to
rewatch after endgame okay we open on
the Marvel Studios logo foreshadowing of
course Asgard's fiery end along with the
fact that Thor is saying everything he's
saying to a dead guy ragnaroks end it's
truly in at the beginning here it's a
story about accepting fate in the way
that Tony Stark's third film was a
confession about the story behind his
destroyed home doors third film Stokes
is similar fire searcher here promises I
will tower over the mountains and bury
my so deep in a spa.i hilarious rotating
allows him to immaturely turn a blind
eye to searchers promise but Ragnarok as
a concept is a mythological phase
another step in the cycle the rotation
that a more mature one-eyed Thor will
learn to accept as his natural fate his
summoning of Mjolnir is delayed as it
has been before and immigrant song plays
led zeppelin's Viking war cry with
lyrics like hammer of the gods
Valhalla I am coming how was the song
not been used in the Thor movie yet the
rock music signals ragnaroks departure
from its predecessors but also its
restoration to the true themes of Norse
mythology of destruction Taiki keeps the
camera point of view on Mjolnir kind of
giving it life and soul during its final
victory before its destruction but also
like all things post Ragnarok it gets
reborn and transformed it in game
summoning Thor with the Bifrost is
scourge Karl Urban our man from the boys
his ladies later show up on the Bifrost
bridge they lead the fight against him
put in even more of a face on the
Asgardians he betrayed and the Bifrost
severs the head of that fire dragon a
wonderful heightened on that gag of the
severed police car in dark world you
know every day I said here in the blue
dungeon and wish that I could break out
and upgrade my digs well now with hustle
castle we can all be the Lords of our
own medieval castles your warriors
attack enemy fortresses and earn your
rewards that you can use to build up
your castle just like my dad and a home
depot Garden Isle when I was growing up
you can build up your archers and swords
men to fight invading or
Giants and Dragons who serve the demonic
laws of the abyss I liked fighting these
fire monster guys which look a lot like
the anxiety dreams that give me night
sweats you mix the match the armor and
weapons of your warriors to make them
better in battle here's a tip you can
get more inhabitants in your castle to
help you by adding living rooms that
make them reproduce just like my dad in
the Home Depot garden I'll find my clan
name under new rock stars and join it so
that we can play together
download hustle castle via my link below
enter your nickname and get a special
bonus for new players 250 diamonds and
thirty-five hundred gold pieces again
you can download hustle castle via my
link below and enter your nickname for a
special new player bonus with Loki
posing as Odin since dark world Asgard
has now been Loki 5 he erected a huge
statue he actually embodies this exact
pose later when he returns to save them
in the theater where he stages his own
tribute played has Loki antlers on it
the play romanticizes Loki's fake death
on sparkle pine I took him to it for him
Matt Damon plays Loki and not to him
playing the angel Loki Kevin Smith's
Dogma Luke Hemsworth this Thor and taiko
pal sam neill plays odin and if you
listen closely the chorus is actually
singing the funeral theme that we heard
for Frigga in the dark world
[Music]
[Applause]
actually later Loki will continue
printing his legend his later story
being about him letting go and falling
from Asgard at the ending of the first
film also gonna mention of a pastime
Loki turned four into a frog which is
actually a nod to a 1986 Walt Simonson
comic where Loki does this there's also
a frog version of Thor in the comics
called frog always got to bring that up
whenever I can Thor also calls back
another Simonson comic moment by
threatening Loki with his returning
hammer nothing will stop me as it
returns to my hand well on to the
Bifrost up to Midgard they actually
passed through what looks like an eye
similar to Stephen strange is passing
through and I Heimdall's orange eyes
normally are the link between realms but
this pupil is green which is a color of
scourge his eyes who has taken over the
Bifrost for the moment see Acres
retirement home is a long time gag for
movies and TV and I've seen in South
Park it's originally from East Ventura
when it was actually a pun on that
movies writers named Tom Shadyac for
disguises mule near as an umbrella which
is a nod to his comics secret identity
Donald Blake who did that though dr.
strange sees right through that illusion
of Thunder Lukey says can't seen at the
future I'm not a witch then why'd you
dress like one after in Gabe came out
some fans realized that this is how
Frigga who is a witch so quickly
recognized her son's future self and
here a fangirl says sorry I hear that
Jane dumps you this is actually a cameo
by Chris Hemsworth's cousin Taylor
Hemsworth Thor thinks Loki turning to a
card but then he meets dr. strange and
behind them are the crims advances
interact that strange used to dominate
case ileus now before the awesome self
refilling beers strange offers Thor
t-this is from the same type of teacup
that strange was offered by the ancient
one at comer Taj that tea was to help
settle strangest stomach before he was
transported around the multiverse
strange is making the same offer to for
here but Thor's choice of beer makes his
dizziness for Beatrice workaround a lot
worse now in detail we have pointed out
before to find Odin strange uses Thor's
hair to make Odin's triquetra symbol
which is also in Odin's vault and on
Mjolnir when he charmed it with a
whisper
they find him in Norway Sons
I've been waiting for you boki is
surprised to be called one of his sons
despite his betrayal which is a regret
that he will echo in Infinity Ward I
Loki Prince of Asgard Odense Odin warns
is already begun she's coming my life
was all that held her back but my time
has come I cannot keep it away any
longer
oh who you told me about goddess
suggests hello the firstborn your sister
Wow we did get a hint to this secret
firstborn from Frigga and for full
holding son my heir
my firstborn
and when Odin dies his particles float
out to sea like frege's did except here
we don't see whether they get sucked up
to Valhalla or not which reflects Odin's
moral cloudiness before he dies he
leaves them with this member this page
oh of course this right here is near
tonsberg norway the sight of his frost
giants battle in the first Thor movie
and the church in the cap one prologue
and of course the future home of new as
garden in game hella arrives fans last
year noticed her clothes are torn but
they get repaired when her strength is
restored an Asgard Neil Thank You fun
Loki doesn't miss a beat because she
just took his favorite order
hella catches mule near and she refuses
to release it when Thor's trying to
recall it later we'll see the Asgard
stealing aren't revealing she once
wielded mule near North or did she
shatters it chases them in the Bifrost
as they sweep the edge of the Bifrost it
breaks up into these crystal shards some
interesting production design reflecting
the fiberglass decomposition of the
footbridge itself hella immediately
kills Volstagg and Fandral and her
coming seizure of Asgard is signaled
with Tyga's framing of her antlers
clutching the palace throughout this
film as her power grows her antlers will
open up wider and wider like deadly
claws reaching up from the underworld to
strangle the roots of future sill as we
fly to Sekar we passed one planet in the
shadow of an eclipse I wonder if this
could be Vermeer reveals an infinity war
which was cast in the shadow of a thick
Eclipse but then again sparks wolf I'm
also petting eclipse could be that
there's a lot of eclipses points are
eclipses are cool once the car
authorities fought over my scrappers and
Valkyrie the net and the obedience chip
that they were straining with that he
can't get out of even with his god of
thunder powers connect to his central
nervous system notice the blue streaks
that they nodes in the chip lead in his
skin Thor's dumb face bushes against the
window of their ship setting up his
upcoming meeting with the Guardians an
infinity war scrapper won't fall to any
tunes and
one for two was reference to the comic
Incredible Hulk number 142 which is wind
Valkyrie joins Hulk the grandmasters
palace includes statues showing Hulk
along with past champs saluting Marvel
figures like Ares by Beast Man Thing and
beta ray bill the korbinite Thor
successor who might have shown up in
skull form a few places that we've seen
hello white Southie Asgardian defenses
including Hogan she crushes one guy's
helmet around his head cracking it and
as we saw with Melia before the camera
stays fixed on the hilt of her dagger as
she takes down the soldier Thor enters
the Grand Master's Palace surrounded by
cosmic gateways Sekar lives on the edge
of the known and unknown it is the
collection point the music here is pure
imagination from Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory a movie that has a
similar nightmare tunnel sequence
conducted by an eccentric goof one of
the past victors Thor passes is this
three-headed fella named hey Joe
we actually see him later in his three
heads our mocap and stunt actor Shane
Rangi in the middle Taika Waititi 's
head on the right and Chris Hemsworth's
head on the left now the Grandmaster is
an elder of the universe brother to tan
Elliot Vaughn the collector he pardons
cousin Carlo and then kills I pardon you
huh
you're officially pardoned from life
whoa plumes gesture is a super dark
reference to Schindler's List go ahead
leave yeah so like Ray finds the Grand
Master's pretty evil
Loki calls back the joke from Avengers
he's my brother
I talk to God and he's my brother he
killed 80 people in two days he's
adopted and Thor meets Korg voice and
performed by Taika Waititi
along with meek now Korg is a Crone in
one of whom for rekt in the dark world
and two others a guardian zip by in
volume 2 you don't need to be afraid
unless you made of scissors just a
little rock paper scissor joke for you
now later Korg says that he stepped on
meek who has scissor arms rock beats
scissors and this joke extends back to
when Drax said about this occurrence I
think
Karnas paper people so paper imprisons
rock Korg introduces us to Doug Doug his
Doug Oh Doug Steve Doug is purple with
green clothes matching Thor's street
clothes earlier and they're both
inverses of Hulk's purple on green color
scheme
hello reveals the true history of asgard
just no one remember me there's no one
been taught oh history Paula is obsessed
with her reputation and placement in
history it's come to my attention you
don't know who I am like for hella fails
to understand that Ragnarok must wipe
Asgard slate completely clean including
her history now the mural that she
brought down showed lafi from the frost
giants in the first film remember him
one underneath shows a red sky
reflecting a blood of their enemies with
hella on the back of the wolf
Fenris there's also a heart of her
wielding Mjolnir herself in Odin's vault
hella clears up the old Infinity
Gauntlet plot hole through the casket of
ancient winters week she approves of the
tesseract because it's a freakin
infinity stone but she shrugs off search
her smaller than I thought of me her
underestimation of searcher will come
back to hunter Korg shows up a
three-pronged wooden weapon we use a big
wooden fork yeah not really useful
unless you're fighting off three
vampires that were huddled together
yeah tiger's nodding to his film what we
do in the shadows which also became a
great FX comedy series it's about three
vampires who live together in a cramped
home Stan Lee shows up cutting Thor's
hair now if you think about he must have
also cut Hulk's hair I don't know how he
would have done that because Hulk's hair
is shorter hear that when we saw it in
age of Ultron Thor enters the arena
watch out for his fingers they make
sparks throw away here but his inner god
of thunder powers are his secret weapon
later on now the grandmasters booth like
all the set design in this movie is
inspired very much by the artwork of
Jack Kirby in taiga in a nod to Jack
here the background wallpaper is a color
version of Kirby's Fantastic Four cover
Hulk is introduced here with these green
smoke bombs the color green in this
movie has always signaled a threat to
Thor Loki hella but now with hokey sees
a friendly threat that he might be able
to use
incredible
Hulk cuts off the Grand Master sentence
because as we've seen being identified
as Hulk not banner is a big deal to him
so when Thor calls him banner here he's
hostile vana I never thought I would say
this but I I'm happy to see you
[Applause]
hey vana no burner only hope later Thor
successfully learns to call Hulk by his
name and Hulk corporates oh stop
just for once in your life don't slash
or tries to recreate Natasha Suns
getting real low chant from each of
Ultron but Hulk smash his Thor around
like how we did with Loki and Avengers
and in the final blow of this fight
[ __ ] comes down if you look closely
you can see a bit of green Hulk green
reflected in Thor's eye Thor begins to
plot his escape when he first sees his
Devil's anus and he notices the ship
exploding as he tries to get out tell
him that he needs to have the right ship
to get out of here but really what I
love about this scene is the way the
direction of the actors and the VFX on
naked Hulk do such a great job selling
the gross gag here so right as Holt gets
out of the hot tub there's just a few
frames where they slipped in a shadow
for the Hulk's Rick and Morty just give
us a really gross term for this but you
know that the V the vas be implying
something is tugging the muscle groups
downward there and as hall passes Thor
chris hemsworth looks all the way up
not just the bit up but like all the way
because Holt's crotch would line up with
its chest and we get some hope but which
comes as the literal butt of the joke
Hulk throws fruit pass Thor to trick
Thor into thinking the doorway is safe
to pass through baby lumps what I am
going
[Music]
later Thor and Hulk do work together to
escape
Hulk starts to see my bouncing the ball
against the wall who's that red circles
target it's paint has worn down from all
the other times Hulk has hit it but that
ball is actually a critical part of this
escape plan because hole passes it to
four and Thor uses it to crack the
window that's woody so that he can use
that blue shin guard from the battle
earlier to crash through it there's
actually a moment where Thor signals
Hulk to get ready to pass it to him and
that's where Hulk gets confused and he
fumbles it he's to the Quinjet where he
learns Tony's nickname for him Point
Break welcome yes a callback to Avengers
no hard feelings Point Break you got a
mean swing
Hulk sees Natasha's video message from
the end of age of Ultron and Hulk's eyes
moisten a little as he softens and
reverts to banner banner sees his face
superimposed on the Hulk's which could
be a nod to him using identities an end
game though Taika Waititi said that he
had no idea what they were gonna do in
Avengers in game so it's probably just
the duel I did indeed jekyll-and-hyde
imagery that we've always seen with Hulk
tige uses this crazy shot on looking at
Valkyrie with the camera swooping up
through the floor revealing their
reflections to be the real them it
parallels a famous shot that Robert
Zemeckis used in the movie contact and
the next scene will reflect the true
soul of Valkyrie who mourns for Valkyrie
or she actually returns with a Pegasus
and endgame love that coming back but
for this flashback the crew used a
technology called dynamic light
combining high-speed cameras with
shifting lights and shadows to create
the effect of a disoriented memory
Banner where's Tony Stark's clothes
including a Duran Duran hungry like a
wolf shirt setting up banners can we
battle with the wolf Fenris and in the
braid it gets dusted and green you can
see a brief league dancing with everyone
the banner has to hide his holiness for
Valkyrie by wiping off the screen but
it's a losing battle because the walls
of this place are bright green
reflecting green light on his face
Valkyrie mentions and are from guardians
of the galaxy she longs and on we can be
back in Asgard in 18 minutes and banner
describes that Devil's anus that looks
like a collapsing neutron star inside of
an einstein-rosen bridge einstein-rosen
bridge is a wormhole we learned that in
the first solar einstein-rosen bridge oh
what a nice town Rosen bridge is a
theoretical connection between two
different points of space the wormhole
Thor and Loki use their old get help
move to escape
behind them is a ship that's just a
floating cube that tyka claimed to
design all by himself I designed this
and it's now in a movie that doesn't get
paid for it lookey betrayed Thor
everyone's was sentiment way easier to
let it burn yeah look II ends up being
right in the final act except fate let
it burn they escaped through the devil's
anus to return to Asgard
during this hella fine time dolls hiding
spot tipping over the door with me huge
steel tree engraving that she uses it as
a drawbridge reflecting her in here to
use Heimdall's Bifrost bridge across
need yourself to the other realms now
one of the more obvious details in this
movie that you probably caught the mural
rubble showing Thor's face cracked
through his right eye of course
foretelling this coming loss of that eye
but what I love about this is the
thematic connection of the first film
that blindness comes right as Thor
finally sits on Odin's throne it
completes the coronation that was
deferred in that movies opening act
according mythologies Odin gave up his
eye to obtain cosmic wisdom and so too
must Thor in order to rise to the throne
banner recreates that goofy helicopter
die from the first Hulk movie alright
now I got this
[Music]
but he does hook out he pulls back then
rice and in this plate you can see how
the artists kept that chest scar from
the moment abomination stabbed him there
in a vision
Odin tells Thor that Asgard is not a
place it's a peephole I think this way
said and he helps them summon his inner
god of thunder powers immigrant song
returns in Thor cleans up now I love how
he still wears the piece of this sack
our gladiator armor on his shoulder
being a garbage warrior is now part of
his identity shortly after the movie
came out a few years ago sword fighting
experts pointed out how Thor is using
half sorting here he's clubbing enemies
with the hilt and that's because he's
more accustomed to fighting with a
hammer than a blade scourge redeems his
betrayal by firing Dez and Troy on
Hellas army this is adapted from an epic
moment in the comic scourge his final
stand and gala brew loki resurrect
searcher and pauses on the tesseract
which we know he takes from the opening
act of infinity war and searcher does
his promised he brings about Ragnarok
they include this shot of this world
Street getting swept up in the flames
pieces isn't just about Asgard it's
about all of life on the Asgardian
refugee trip Thor tries to peg loki
again thinking he's just appear in via
projection but this time he's actually
real he catches it
but notice Thor wouldn't have hit Loki's
head because his missing eye is throwing
off his aim but still no excuse for not
going for the head-on Panos now one of
my favorite details that fans have
spotted a couple years ago in the final
shot when Loki passes Hulk Hulk briefly
makes a fist still not forgiving them
from Avengers what I love about it is
they always do this with Hulk they
included this gesture in endgame as well
with Hulk and Loki atop Avengers Tower
during the time hikes accepting their
fate of their home's obliteration they
all realize that Asgard is not a place
it's a peep hell I think that's what it
is and they set course for their new
home of new Asgard on earth but we know
from the post-credits scene and the
opening act infinity war that only half
of these as Guardians will make it but
the good news is since they've already
been halved and no more of them will
dust when the snap happens therefore
when the surviving as Guardians reach
their destination they will be steps
ahead on the road to recovery and that's
all because they're leaders in this
movie learned it taught them that death
is a natural part of our fates that we
must accept
Ragnarok as the film matured all of us
to better prepare us for the darkness
coming of infinity war join our future
watch along son discord by becoming a
patreon at patreon.com slash new rock
stars and
more reminder to download hustle castle
using my link below in the description
nickname for eight special new player
bonus follow me on Instagram and Twitter
a DA vas follow me rock stars and
subscribe as we move on to how I first
reacted to those yummy looking foodies
of Wakanda
[Music]